alors darry cowl vous êtes affiche
jusqu'au 31 décembre 2002 d'une pièce
qui s'appelle [ __ ] de soirée au
gymnase donc ça hein vous de ville de
daniel nicolas avec patrick chesnais
anémone florence gentil monique tarbès
et vous voilà alors le pitch je vais le
faire
patrick chesnais est un homme d'affaires
ruiné qui se voit contraint de vendre en
une nuit sans hôtel particulier avant
saisie alors évidemment tous les
acheteurs sont conviés à dîner pour
cette ultime dîner vous vous êtes le
majordome alcoolo et la soirée vire bien
sûr au cauchemar puisque vous essayer de
l'aider mais en fait c'est pas du tout
le plan qui l'a patrick chesnais on va
[ __ ] le bordel quoi
oui j'ai bien j'ai le rôle d'un
majordome et j'assiste à 7 cette maison
qui veulent pas un jour ne pas dire
bonjour il a six ils insistent au des
gars qui vont se passer durant toute la
soirée
voilà alors voilà et ça n'arrête pas
moins jeunes homos jette du 1er étage 3
je suis délabré je dirais qu'on peut
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas grand sage
combien étaient des més et puis voilà et
puis ça se termine jeudi pas la fin
parce que ben non bah il faut pas le
dire
voilà ça s'appelle [ __ ] de soirée avec
patrick chesnais anémone et darry cowl
jour merci beaucoup au revoir
vous
du tout c'est loin d'être fini de rire
on va parler de vous d'abord vous
appelez pas du tout darry cowl méandres
et d'haricots oui vous êtes né en 1925
ouais et vous êtes appelés darry cowl
parce que vous étiez dans le jazz ça
faisait américain exactement voilà un et
votre arrière grand père était un
médecin de napoléon oui il est exact
aussi voilà à bayonne et votre père est
un grand médecin basse que lui aussi
d'ailleurs ah bah oui
le problème c'est que vous êtes né d'une
union illégitime entre votre père et une
fille qui était venue accoucher chez lui
mais qui après vous abandonnez oui par
abandonner c'est beaucoup dire
et les bourgeois basque c'est une race
très spécial et est bon il fallait que
ça reste secret ouais dont je connais
pas ma mère voilà l'enjeu de belle mère
pour faire croire que c'était elle qui
avait eu un enfant elle se baladait avec
d'avex un petit coussin gonflable mois
en mois comme ça pour que vous apprenez
la vérité à l'âge de 10 ans oui et vous
avez malgré tous vos efforts jamais
retrouvé votre mère non mais c'est pas
grave si c'est pas grave maintenant
c'est trop tard
je crois qu'il est parti vous avez
arrêté il complètement de la suivre
alors votre belle-mère vous a jamais
vraiment aimé darry cowl parce que votre
père d'abord est mort à 8 ans et ça vous
a posé quand même des père est mort il
avait huit ans son père elle devrait
faire un break on lui met une pile 9 ans
va fumer un club dans le coeur
attendons maintenant que les vases ou
tard il revient dans un quart d'heure il
en sera la même question
ballmer ne vous a jamais aimé darry cowl
en plus votre père était mort quand vous
aviez 8 ans et ça crée chez vous un
certain problème psychologique j'imagine
non non pas du tout à 17 ans vous faites
émancipé pour épouser une femme de 36
ans donc c'est bien la preuve quand même
que vous aviez un manque énorme ce côté
là oui mais ma mère j'ai j'ai été gentil
avec elle parce que mon père adorait
contrevent jouer rien à [ __ ] oui vous
êtes bien m'occuper d'elle quand elle
était malade à votre belle mère
j'étais habitué ça fait 6 imite les j1
dont je passais mon temps à l'hôpital
c'est pas ça qui responsable de votre
fameux bégaiement en fait quand vous
aviez 7 8 ans vous aviez fait peur à une
vieille tante dans une église à 10 ans
cowboys est sorti de derrière un pylône
dans une église de menton s'est fait
voler ma wii et là on vous a pris on
vous a amené à la maison et on vous a
suspendu pendant deux trois minutes au
dessus du vide oui ils vont qu'il y
avait déjà du vertige quand vous mentiez
sur une chaise oui ça vous a
complètement flinguer ça ab oui j'ai
signé ici mais les boutons de mon
pantalon pète je vais me casser la
gueule c'est évidemment ils ont tenu
ils ont heureusement alors ensuite vous
faites du fait du conservatoire en fait
du cabaret vous êtes accompagnateurs des
plus grands de l'époque de l'époque ils
sont tous mais ils sont partis à oued
aker guéthary il ya plus qu'un amoureux
qu'elle a dans tout ce que vous avez
accompagné elle même l'amour viaduc
robert lamoureux oui et alors un jour
justement vous accompagner robert
lamoureux dans les arènes de béziers
il pleut des cordes lamoureux est en
retard
il vous dit fait les patientes et enfin
modifier les patientes et et vous fait
patienter les gens avec une boîte
d'allumettes et vous fait marrer
onze mille personnes avec une boîte
d'allumettes pendant une demi heure
j'adore c'est un million mais j'ai été
mouillé parce qu'il pleuvait ouais et je
réclamais mais je pouvais pas lui mais
l'a lui-même parce qu'il pleurait
c'était le l'explosif et j'ai fait une
demi heure avec ça les mecs étaient
morts de rire il devenu une star mais à
quoi ça tient
alors vos sketches et est toujours basé
sur des trucs pas drôle au départ
accompagné j'accompagnais puis entre les
numéros
j'ai juge nous l'avait dit je jettent en
démon loges ce public était ravi le
public savait des gouttes sur la tête
oui oui oui il était ravi et enchanté
ouais et c'est là que j'ai connu guitry
sacha guitry
ah oui puycelsi s'ils m'avaient tourner
un film très vite après assassins et
voleurs oui mais non ah ouais grand film
voilà après donc il ya le cabaret des
trois baudets qui était un grand cabaret
des années 50 ans 54 donc vous commencez
le cinéma et le théâtre
il vous fait le triporteur qui est un
énorme succès un set c'est c'est eh oui
c'était un grand succès oui et nord moi
je me souviens j'étais un bon ben ça
sens bien aussi un supporter a été oui
ah ouais non non il ya cette phrase qui
restera partout c'était au petit
canaillou paix et et rebondit j'ai sorti
s'affirmant dit oui et là
malheureusement vous vous accrochez à
une drogue dure
le jeu voilà ohlala ouais j'ai sauvé et
pour payer vos dettes de jeu darry cowl
vous allez faire beaucoup de navets
surtout des navets que des navets disons
le mais bah oui parce que je téléphonais
la nuit pour eu à mon agent gilles fau
vie d'un film et lequel je m'en fous je
vais signer j'ai signé des films samson
l'émirat alors ce tunnel matin
l'après-midi à nos deux films est
souvent le soir à notre film encore
dingue effet plaints ces ingrats oui
s'agit là je n'avais alors vous avez
planté votre votre carrière
quand cette passion du jeu a duré quand
même 15 ans non oui puce ouais j'ai
perdu une plus qu'on le croit et moins
qu'on pense et en plus d'être d'harry
guignard en plus quoi c'est à dire que
vous gagnez pas souvent qua non qui a eu
la chance d'être malchanceux
ah oui c'est vrai je venais quand
j'allais dans un casino un sac de jeu
les gens téléphonaient venez vite yade
eric au caylar venez vite il jouait
contre moi ils gagnaient moins sûr alors
effectivement le public au départ et
vous adorez et puis comme faisais
n'importe quoi un moment c'est un peu
comme une maîtresse qu'on délaisse quoi
c'est à dire que finalement tu dis vous
à - exactement
oui donc mais maintenant je m'efforce
d'être d'être plus mieux élevés en
bégayant pas à vous bb plus du tout là
bientôt avoir un
et bien non bah on vous félicite on va
vous applaudir
alors
quand je lui qu'avait le jeu n'avait pas
que le jeu et l'alcool aussi vous étiez
capable de vous envoyer une bouteille de
porto une bouteille de scotch comme
savoir pourquoi une wii dizaines et des
dizaines de ces incroyables
j'ai connu avec francis bélanger que
nous l'époque bière de francis alors
c'était la bière j'ai connu l'époque
porto j'ai connu l'époque 20 et j'écris
maintenant une petit peu de pastis c'est
tout comme c'est tout ouais c'est
vachement raisonnable très ouais y avait
des cigarettes aussi fut le cas pour les
4 jours 3 j'allumais le matin et je n'y
ai d'ailleurs j'étais n'y est pas c'est
la nuit ses lauriers l'édredon qu'ils
éteignaient vous êtes bien conservé
malgré tout ça c'est un croissant 17 ans
voilà vous avez les dons des tons qu'on
connaît pas vous êtes médium en fait et
pendant l'occupation vous vous rendiez
impasse du cardinal mercier à clichy
chez eux chez deux anglaises arrêts et
elle s'est servie de vous pour entrer en
contact avec l'au delà
entrant riches voilà antilles en transe
et vous vous en faites vous souvenez de
rien quoi vous savez sérieux c est très
sérieux et que j'avais les médecins et
prenais ma tension il me réveillait
doucement vais me réveiller il mais
c'était de la transe avec précaution y
avait le docteur guerni qui s'occupait
de vous à ce moment là claude vernick
l'autre guerre mais comment il sait ça
fait c'est vrai et alors quand vous
sortiez de live vous donnez votre argent
quand vous sortiez de la evous baladier
dans la rue malgré malgré le couvre-feu
imposé par nos soins il s'en régaler en
langue josiane ausweis mais vous dites
les allemands ne m'approcher pas car ma
silhouette était auréolé de moss était
complètement électrique a pressé sur le
récent gt c'est bizarre gt oui c'est
vrai
métier complètement électrique quoi vous
aviez le sentiment d' éclairer les gens
ah oui oui c'était dingue ouais mais
c'est une époque que je serais devenu
fou
vous avez arrêté ouais et alors après
dans les années 50
vous avez vu des soucoupes volantes
aussi oui c'est vrai ça je suivrai
l'histoire des scoops vannes angers
assure pierre j'ai vu ça il ya entendu
c'était entre nice et cassis vous
ameniez la chanteuse accepte les souris
nourries qui était avec sa mère sa mort
mais à un moment dans un tournant vous
voyez une soucoupe volante
oui mais riez pas c'est vrai
moi je sais que c'est vrai d'harry
laisser les rires moi je sais que vous
étiez dans une traction je me souviens
très bien et la mère de souris quand
elle a du sel a failli tomber dans les
pommes
mais pourquoi la faille et elle est
tombée dans la vallée et moi j'étais
tout content voilà je crois pas aux
petits bonshommes verts mais je m'en aux
objets comme ça qui circulent on va on
va dans les dix ans où on lira à 20 km
de saturne et de mars
je vois pas pourquoi il y aurait pas
d'autres y a pas que nous bien sûr merci
beaucoup
bien sûr surtout surtout faut bien le
dire que vous en avez revu
quand vous étiez en chine avec belmondo
vous avez revu des soucoupes volantes
oui mais sachez pas sûr
la première fois c'est sûr comment j ai
bavé des ronds s'est passé presque
serrer la main
1 ouais c'était tout près oui puis c'est
parti
c'est parti comme ça ouais ouais comme
les soupes des banques comme les
soucoupes volantes d'ailleurs bon